bps number one
tlc the pinnacle of class we've seen
adults obsessions and they thought for
some reason
that kid's obsession was appropriate
and here we are reacting to it can't
wait
let's go this child this nine-year-old
is obsessed with collecting cockroaches
which one of you is it fed us up right
now
can you cancel a child story i don't
want to go to bed
oh god it's right there
like that hey okay kids time to get up
and eat it's time for bed babe
oh god what's with the milk oh god is it
for the cockroaches
does she dip the cockroaches in milk
like cookies why my brain go in here i
don't know
[Laughter]
what
[Music]
no no
oh god hi my name is shelby catterman i
am nine years old and i collect
cockroaches
oh don't kiss it you can't do that you
can keep them in a little cage
okay as a pet i would allow that
oh god why you gotta do that when i
started collecting roaches i only had
five that's five too many i hope you
understand this
how you don't collect that oh oh and now
i have thousands
teach the world to not be afraid of
cockroaches i don't think i need to
be taught that another one thank you
they say children helps us open our eyes
to a different
point of view and i know
what the [ __ ] what i want roaches
because when they call my arms they
tickle me and why hold on they can be
real happy
uh i could do without him but
explain yourself that how do you let
this happen i absolutely
don't love the cockroaches
but i can deal with them i do have freak
out moments every once in a while
oh my god get those ew the tiny ones why
would you have the tiny ones
why would you have any of these
get them all never just escape mommy
but overall you know i've come to accept
shelby's passions
my favorite thing about roaches is that
they are
special oh god they're huge they could
eat her they could eat her
if the parents leave her alone one day
she'd be gone bing bang
they bite right oh god they're so nasty
looking my favorite thing about
cockroaches is that someday
in the near future that they will all go
away
[Music]
well you're not helping are you we all
wish that was the thing
case ah
i want to teach people about my roaches
because they're not monsters and they
can be really cute and
funny funny huh
yeah they tell a joke huh yeah righteous
she is pregnant and oh is that what that
was i wasn't sure what that was but that
just
i don't like the uh oh
you can see her a casino
these are my madagascar hissing
cockroaches
they're hiss and sometimes they're too
noisy they will hit
them the exoskeleton is their bones on
the outside of their body
they shed their exoskeleton and they
turn snow
white for just a couple of hours and
then they get their normal color back
oh that's creepy the roaches they do not
buy
they're not harmful at all except they
may be a little stinky once in a while
yeah at least they don't bite okay that
makes it a little better but stinky
we trade bite with stinky look at her
what is happening here maybe tone it
down maybe say no
maybe say hey you can get one toy at the
toy store two once in a while
this is what i think it's a german
beetle i use
them to clean up the dead bugs in my
cage so it doesn't smell so bad
oh my god of course there's got to be so
many dead ones
they eat themselves they eat the flesh
off bones
oh oh that's a nice sentence to hear
from a nine-year-old
cockroaches shelby cockroach oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] bravest man is cameraman
well this is interesting no judgment i'm
just not coming over for dinner
burn the house burn it down god damn it
here's one less offense said at least as
i understand
uh he's obsessed with vacuums that's my
dream
if i have a child i'll make them like
obsessed with cleaning or something and
i'll forever have
a free cleaning lady cleaning lady man
the only thing
13 year old logan holes of sibley iowa
likes more than the sound
i can't i can't hear from vacuum
cleaners why's that
feeling of one in his hands i feel joy
when i vacuum
i always vacuum at least three or four
times a day just to get that nice
feeling
here you just you [ __ ] walk mate say
hey
hey all right kids can like anything
clearly er
what's up in the morning he tricks the
vacuum on
that's a cool vacuum then he comes
downstairs got a light on it you can
vacuum in the dark that's
sick and then through my living room
through the dining room
and then my kitchen and he will come
home from school
then vacuum again
it makes me feel kind of annoyed because
there's always a vacuum running
yes that's can't really concentrate on
what i want to do
[Applause]
he brings him out with him okay of
course i usually like to go
to other places the vacuum my mom works
at the hair salon that makes sense
i like to go there he likes to come down
here obviously
and do some vacuuming of the hair and of
course we need it done
daily and so he will come down and do
the daily here
and then when i'm done at my mom's salon
my dad's a fire chief
so i vacuum the fire hall i like having
logan down hey he's got the henry
let's go everyone in uk has that vacuum
and i've never seen it in my entire life
but
literally everyone do you have this one
in other countries
this is everywhere everyone has the
henry and he
takes care of he's like my maid if you
will but he makes sure
there you go there you go that's what i
said you get personal free mane
your son's the vacuum kid
next thing you know we're receiving
vacuums from these people that were
broken
and uh most of people thought to just
let them play with them and experiment
with them and things like that
but now he's repairing him and handing
it back to him so here's your vacuum
back
and they're going i just gave it to you
to play with
expected return in working condition
i mean it seems he's like a young
entrepreneur if you can make you can
make a business out of this and then you
get personal
slate and a personal income personal
free
uh work uh okay i wanted to
add to my collection hey brenda logan
got a vacuum for you so i created a
business logan's miracle world there we
go
cleaner repairs hell yeah it should be
okay thank you
every time i fix a vacuum cleaner i feel
like a detective trying to find out a
crime it's
a screws i usually try to dig deep far
into the vacuum
if i find something odd looking i always
take that apart
and put a new one back in do you think
he knows what he's doing the most
important part about fixing a vacuum
cleaner
is having to test the vacuum cleaner to
see if it runs
i use glitter as my test dust because
it's one of the hardest substituents
to vacuum up he speaks english as well
as i
hardest says this is digital
wow
[Music]
perfect it's kind of well it's better
than cockroaches okay can we get agree
on that
rather than drinking selling drugs
something yeah i think well you're
setting the bar
pretty low i love when kids do that like
at least i'm not out doing drugs and
drinking and we're like oh yeah cool so
you're not doing the worst thing you
could be doing
thank you thank you so much child well
you want me to bow huh
what do you want me to kiss your feet
what is this
at least i'm not out doing crack okay
you wouldn't even know where to buy
crack cocaine [ __ ]
i see who you hang around with he's no
longer weird if he made it into a
business smart man yeah
see that's what i was hoping for and he
did so cool good for him i'm okay with
this one
this one gets the pass uh moving up in
the age bracket but
this girl is obsessed with celebrity
stalking five-year-old vanessa sky ellis
spends every day on the hunt for
celebrities are you from one direction
[Music]
nope i am not uh
what was that real good over the past
seven years she's managed to grab over
ten thousand autographs and
whoa with famous people
i i'll go after whoever whenever that's
mario katone
can i get her autograph sir she's got a
high standard
i'll go after anyone whoever this is
like the worst people
i meet because i can tell when someone
just wants a photo because they think
you're famous right
and when they're actually watch your
channel or whatever
celebrities fighting is the most
important thing to me
it's more important than having a
boyfriend than
going to work than doing anything
can i get a quick photo i have no idea
who that is thank you
oh wow love that that was jan well that
was a genuine nice
um exchange right
bye look at the smile
thank you whoa dude
so fake bye-bye
[Applause]
vanessa works nights as a bartender so
she can spend her days running around
the city
tracking down celebrities maybe i only
sleep like two hours of sleep because
then in the morning
what a sentence i sleep two hours of
sleep
you don't [ __ ] say do you but getting
to actually meet someone famous
isn't always as easy as it looks i was
wondering is there any way i can get in
um right backstage that didn't work
i was wondering whether is there
anything there where
oh my god what if i saw bts one day that
would be a dream
her apartment walls are plastered with
just a small portion of the ten thousand
photos she's taken over i mean that's
quite a name
collection
photos or celebrities and i have about
30 different boxes i want to see the
ones she took that
isn't a celebrity but she mistook it for
one because those are always so funny
that she has to have a lot of them and
she doesn't favor one star over another
a photo with political figure al
sharpton is just as treasured as a photo
with hollywood superstar
angelina jolie a snapshot with pat sajak
he's meeting the jersey shores paulie d
no i don't think i think they're equally
sh i don't have no idea who
who the first guy is and i don't think
paulie
uh i mean there's no such thing as a
celebrity being an e-lister
or a b-lister or a c-list was that james
c
did i see that right no i can't tell no
it isn't there or
c-lister the old celebrities luke perry
green day meatloaf alan [ __ ]
zac efron donnie osmond me getting
another photo with somebody
that's me achieving that makes me feel
good jason tam
jason tam jason tam jason tam
why do you have to do the same stop
leave jason tam
or whatever alone please leave him alone
he didn't do nothing oh god that was
beautiful love that
all right if you enjoyed this video hit
like subscribe i got way more tlc videos
if you want to check them out and thank
you
uh for watching and i'll see you
tomorrow profits